y lo que vemos aquí es precisamente lo
que iba a ser mi siguiente pregunta y es
un gran cambio de tono en celensky desde
el día de ayer hasta el día de hoy
cuando ayer decía que era ridículo que
no existiera un calendario para la
adhesión Y hoy ha dedicado sus discursos
a agradecer por esas ganancias que dice
ha tenido en esta Cumbre Cuáles son esas
ganancias para para
yo creo que las ganancias este son más
son más que evidentes es decir por lo
menos
quien se garantiza que la otan por lo
menos en cada país individual
continúe la ayuda militar que requiere
Ucrania en esta guerra
en su propio territorio desde que empezó
la operación especial militar de Rusia
se garantiza no solamente el armamento
sino que se garantiza un marco de
seguridad que le permitiría a Ucrania
poder continuar con esta ayuda militar
que tanto requiere de los países
occidentales sobre todo pues obviamente
Europa y Estados Unidos y se garantiza
también pues que conforme esta guerra
avance sea que
se siente contraofensiva que Ucrania
lanzó para recuperar los territorios de
alguna manera pues le permitan a Ucrania
ir teniendo algunos algunas ganancias
territoriales para hacer que te diga por
lo menos creíble la opción de que
Ucrania eventualmente Podría quizás
ganar esta guerra o incluso cuidado no
perderla pero sin embargo la otan pues
tiene es del criterio que se tiene un
compromiso
adquirido Inevitable ineludible como
Ucrania respecto al tema militar Y
respecto al tema de la seguridad y
respecto al tema de la reconstrucción
del país una vez que termina la guerra
cómo queda entonces la posición de
Ucrania después de esta Cumbre usted
considera que se fortalece o se cambia
su situación en alguna medida
bueno se fortalece porque por lo menos
ya se pasa de lo que antes era
lo que se conocía como la comisión de 31
países de la otan más uno incluido lo
que se conoce digamos en este caso como
Ucrania a convertirse en el consejo de
la otan más Ucrania eso implica de que
ya se está Ya está ya está en marcha los
protocolos que se requieren que son
bastante bastante complicados para
acceder a la otan a pesar de que hay
también de alguna forma un consenso de
muchos países miembros de la otan en
facilitar a través de una de un tipo de
vía rápida la incorporación de Ucrania
una vez que termina la guerra no en el
proceso de la guerra lo que haría Pues
de alguna manera que Ucrania Según como
termine esta guerra Pues podría ser
posible una incorporación rápida a la
otan Así que yo creo que se fortalece de
alguna manera frente a la otan se
fortalece frente a la comunidad
internacional pero Habría que ver cuál
va a ser el curso de la guerra porque
eso es otro otro tema pues bastante
complicado por menos en campo de batalla
que puede incluso alterar mucho
cualquier decisión política que se haya
tomado en esta última cumbre de la otan
Bueno qué tanto alteran las
declaraciones del día de hoy en la
Cumbre de la otan al kremline y habla
demir Putin Porque si viene no hay una
invitación para que Ucrania sea
formalmente uno de miembro más de la
otan si existe esta nueva figura que
usted nos está comentando sobre los
miembros más Ucrania y esta posibilidad
de voladimir se le esquí de citar a los
miembros en pleno de la otan
representar a esto que haya
repercusiones por parte de Rusia en el
terreno
No yo no creo que haya ninguna porque a
pesar de que hay compromisos fuertes de
la otan con Ucrania eso tampoco está
garantizando que exista un calendario
oficial que le permita a Ucrania poder
incorporarse en algún momento de ahí de
ahí un poco digamos la excepción de que
no no se habló de una fecha es que no se
puede hablar de una fecha Mientras que
el país está en guerra no se puede no se
sabe cuánto va a durar la guerra
entonces evidentemente a Putin de alguna
forma también le sirve porque en el
tanto en que la guerra dure más tiempo
más largo se va a hacer el proceso de
incorporación de Ucrania a la otan Así
que yo creo que repito Más allá de
cualquier decisión diplomática más allá
de cualquier discurso Más allá de
cualquier cambio que haya habido
sustancial o mínimo en la otan en esta
última Cumbre lo que va a determinar la
incorporación de Ucrania a la otan va a
ser cuánto va a durar la guerra en el
campo de batalla y eso pues está por
verse todavía más dependiendo de cuál va
a ser la posición de miembros que están
apoyando a Ucrania en este momento
evidentemente y la mayoría de líderes
coinciden en que esta es una guerra que
podría extenderse por mucho tiempo más
ahora sobre el uso anuncios paralelos
que se dieron durante esta Cumbre
mientras que Francia por ejemplo habló
de una nueva entrega de misiles a
Ucrania selensky resaltó sin embargo que
sigue teniendo deficiencias con armas de
largo alcance usted considera que se
podrán esperar mayores entregas para el
país en los meses por venir lo dijo hace
unos minutos Joe biden continuaremos
aquí hasta el momento que sea necesario
Bueno evidentemente sí va a seguir
enviándose material bélico este cada vez
más sofisticado se le es que viene desde
hace muchos meses pidiendo este que se
le envíen aviones para poder enfrentar
El dominio del espacio aéreo que Rusia
hasta el momento ha tenido sobre el
campo de batalla en el digamos en todo
el territorio por lo menos una vuelta
una buena parte del territorio ucraniano
y también un poco pues la la
preocupación que en el ámbito
internacional sobre la decisión de
Estados Unidos de enviar posiblemente
armamento de de racimo lo cual es pues
son prohibidos a nivel de de las
convenciones internacionales porque es
uno de los armamentos más grotescos y
más mortales más letales que puedan
haber Entonces eso es algo que digamos
muchas veces se puede se puede prometer
pero muchas veces puede pasar semanas
para que eso se pueda llegar a concretar
Así que no hay nada seguro aparte de los
ofrecimientos que los países hacen pues
para ver si en efecto ese armamento que
tanto reclama se le esqui puede llegar
realmente al campo de batalla Antonio
ustedes especialista en origen y
ampliación de la otan y quisiera
preguntarle cuál es en su opinión en
este momento el estado de la alianza una
alianza que venía siendo denunciada como
un organismo muy debilitado y que
realmente volvió a ganar mucha
preponderancia a partir desde el inicio
de la Guerra de Ucrania y se ha venido
fortaleciendo tanto así que ya hay dos
nuevos miembros recientemente añadidos
Suecia siendo el gran anuncio del primer
día de la Cumbre Cómo evalúa usted la
situación o la perspectiva de la otan
bueno básicamente yo creo que hay dos
momentos muy importantes uno cuando se
cuando empieza el proceso de expansión
de la otan en la década de los noventas
que fue muy importante nunca se creyó
que la otan pasara digamos de los
miembros fundadores que lo que la crean
en 1949 a incorporar en la década de los
noventas a una gran cantidad de miembros
de la de la antigua esfera del Antiguo
esfera soviética y yo creo que otra
etapa muy complicada que vivió la otan
fue siendo Donald Trump presidente
cuando Donald Trump pues debilitó mucho
a la otan entrando en conflictos por
temas de presupuesto por temas de
cooperación y muchas otras cosas más en
donde históricamente pues Estados Unidos
es el que siempre había puesto la mayor
cuota para poder sostener a esta entidad
militar que de la cual pues se gastan
miles y miles de millones de dólares
anualmente y que incluso para muchos
países europeos implica esta entre el 2
y el cinco por ciento del producto
interno bruto lo cual eso contabiliza
billones de dólares al año pero yo creo
que con la llegada de biden a la
presidencia que se propuso digamos echar
para en este conflicto que Trump había
empezado contra la otan la guerra en
Ucrania de alguna forma vino a
fortalecer a esta entidad militar al
punto Pues que definitivamente con esta
última Cumbre pero sobre todo con la
Cumbre de Madrid que se dio el año
pasado pues simplemente se cambia
completamente el concepto estratégico
militar de la otan para empezar a tener
en China y a Rusia como los principales
adversarios en el sistema internacional
Entonces esta Cumbre reciente que
terminó ayer pues simplemente lo que
hace es que renueva los votos de la
organización como una entidad que
necesita estar lo más unida posible en
caso de que hayan situaciones de futuras
guerras por lo menos en Europa una vez
que la guerra en Ucrania termi